how movies anywhere shows the best
streaming library
is one you control how do you access
your digital content efficiently
it's simple with the help of movies
anywhere you can now bring your favorite
movies together into one collection even
if you purchase
them from different places with movies
anywhere you can have a collection of
all your favorite digital movies in one
location
and if you're looking for a good movie
friday night you no longer have to
wonder if the mask of zorro or
die hard have disappeared you don't have
to check if it's no longer on a
streaming site
the movie is in your digital locker and
you can watch it as many times as you
wish
and whenever you want on any device as
long as you are connected to a movies
anywhere account
the service is free works across
multiple platforms
devices and retailers which makes it a
good umbrella for
all of your movies you can share your
love of movies by sending a screen pass
to friends
and family however you must be 13 years
or older to sign up for movies anywhere
enjoy movies anywhere at movies anywhere
dot com
your movies together at last